hey guys welcome to tech Tuesday or
Thursday or depending upon when I post
this it's supposed to be Tuesdays but
sometimes Tuesday's might not be on a
Tuesday it's like Taco Tuesday but on a
Friday or freedom Friday on a Taco
Tuesday I made a rule for myself because
I'm really bad at filming things or
doing anything consistently it's it's I
know my faults I know my flaws so I
thought to keep the show consistent at
any time I get something cool I'm just
gonna either do an unboxing of it show
it to you guys and I actually bought
this at the Apple Store so this isn't
like a sponsored video or anything I'm
just a really huge Mophie fan and if any
of you guys have ever met me you know
that I've usually got a Mophie brick in
my pockets with a cord hanging out of it
so the chords are usually the problem
and I also travel a lot too so I found
this little USB Mophie travel kit I
haven't opened it yet so this is gonna
be some real crazy first reaction stuff
I'm not good at unboxings as you guys
have seen so you know a lot of people
like having the Mophie cases on their
iPhone I don't because I like having a
seemingly naked iPhone and also a girl
so I carry a purse around guys you can
also I don't know put something in your
pocket this is the Melfi XL which is
absolutely massive in relation to the
phone it's pretty big this will charge
your iPhone about eight times this will
charge your iPhone about eight times I
also use this to keep my GoPros charged
when I'm filming things charges my iPad
is pretty much my Savior but the problem
is the cords so when I saw this little
set looks a little pack ammo fees we're
not there really freaking cute it comes
with the Lightning a microUSB and one of
these old-school iPad iPhone chargers
which is kind of funny because there's
been several times for either I've
needed one or a friend just needed one
or some stranger has needed a cord and I
haven't had it so now I'm prepared so
let's give him a little test dude okay
kind of looks really stupid Bernie was
good to go
it's also very bendy apparently I also
like that I know this is gonna come to a
surprise to some of you but I have an
Android phone
I love Google and Shh there I love Apple
don't get me wrong you guys know that
but I really do love kind of knowing
what else is out there and so when you
guys talk about things with Android I
want to know what's going on and I think
they're doing a lot of interesting stuff
so I this right here is basically my
life it sums it all up so my first
impression is it's pretty awesome
especially if you're traveling because
it's small its compact and it comes with
this little carrying case which I
probably will never use again I wish
this came with a mini USB because the
GoPro charges off of a mini USB and a
lot of my Canon cameras that I have also
charged from the minis who'd probably
not make this anymore the USB travel kit
I like it it's pretty cool I'm sure you
can find it somewhere on the internet
but they do over to the Apple Store this
is the Mophie XL charger they have so
many different ones of these that come
in different sizes so honestly it
depends how much money you want to spend
and it also depends how much power
you're gonna need for me I need as much
as possible so when they make one like
this that's the size of my laptop I
think they actually might have those
already
thanks for watching make sure you leave
me a comment and let me know if there's
anything else cool that you would like
me to check out for a future tech
Tuesday or whenever I post this but it's
still gonna be called tech Tuesday even
it's a Friday so see you later
[Music]